yo dog we are world series we got NFL
yet the NBA Stern got UFC hmm and you
like money yeah you like all those yeah
so when I bet on it bro yeah if you want
to bet on something then you should do
it think of it if you're thinking if
you're riding around your town and
everybody's doing this or have some you
know they got a deal on gum somebody's
dad you know they inherited all the oil
money brah
[ __ ] them what I'm saying is this dude
you can bet on football or baseball or
basketball but you got to do it at my
bookie my bookie dot hey G good day yep
and they double your first deposit when
you use the promo code cat the up K 80s
so say if you're gonna lay down six
dollars you got 12 now dad yeah daddy if
you're gonna bet this season do the
smart thing go with my bookie dot a G
because no one gives you more ways to
way no one think of somebody who who
blue BlueCross BlueShield way body well
wait no but your your local shark yeah
big Tommy Tommy combined Z no no my
bookie dot AG you play you pay you win
trying to keep the lights on look man
holidays are coming up aspera I'm
already lost energy Oh doing in Valhalla
days no energy oh I can't even imagine
dude yeah [ __ ] my mama fruitcake I got
two blenders last year do you know what
I did burn them both bro yeah it's too
much yeah now in that blender burner
yeah dude I'm sending out fruitcakes
left and right yeah you are dude yeah
you are and I got four ships man bro
thank God for ship station station you
want to get rid of your freaking
grandmother dude ship that lady straight
to heaven you feel me yeah boy the hell
no matter where you're selling what
you're selling Amazon Etsy your own
website ship station between all your
orders in one simple interface yep if
you sell them bratwurst you selling
pills whatever do percocets this and
that dude wigs machinery get yourself
together and sausage yeah bruh
no wonder ship stations number one
choice of online sells you ship more in
less time with the best rates available
take the hassle out of the holiday
shipping this year ship yourself leave
your family dude leave your
wife and kids behind bra shook yourself
to Hawaii yeah don't do it the
old-fashioned way on a bus or something
like that man
just use the code cats get a 60 day free
trial that's two months free of no
hassle stress-free holiday ship hey you
cheap bastard dude tighten up a new ship
station it's the number one choice of
online sellers go to ship station
dot-com click on the microphone at the
top of the page and type ke a TS that
ship station comm enter offer code cats
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
dude you're like a fat ambulance that
didn't make the [ __ ] sports team at
school yeah dude
howdy partner he's like a tank I was
like nine tires on it and all of them
are kind of flat dude is spooky near
dude it's pretty scary man
I could barely even see you I can't see
you thank God you have those oh yeah my
eyes are lit up well I guess their wings
those wings need hymns apparently hair
yeah are you a DJ it's like a DJ had a
ready Fred
dude you look like [ __ ] Wyatt slurp
bro you look like a cop at a freaking
bathhouse dude DJ at a rave
[ __ ] dip slow so used to you not
telling good joke almost didn't even
listen to that bro you
[Laughter]
transgender lemonade's now boy there's a
snake in my butt you're like you're like
Steve Irwin but the gay you look like
the first NASA astronaut who's
transgender going to space oh dude big
leap on going only for mankind
I'm going straight into somebody's
wiener bro
that's where I'm going what am i cat cat
got us these beautiful outfits today you
are Buzz Lightyear and Brendon is Woody
Buzz Lightyear from what UFC was he you
not a UFC fighter was he uh no Toy Story
bro Toy Story
apparently Derrick is a green Mike and
Ike that's cool
well no matter what he is he was late
again so it just goes to show you bro
you can't trust pickles broke the city
dude what I'm saying is these pickles
bro you know I'm saying always a few
minutes late to work they don't make it
like they used to
man yeah damn my pickles crunchy not
late Derrick you like ice-t if he was a
[ __ ] cucumber you look like Derrick
looks like Morgan Freeman if he's a
Teletubby yeah they said it would take
out Teletubby 6 or ears to get out of
this your prison Derrick post them did
it in less than seven I'm sweating this
thing out dude he's not breathe well but
you sweat in anything dude especially
this thing though that hat what is it
made out of did it looks like a [ __ ]
like somebody just plastic it's man
applause is it looks like it's caramel I
wish it was this is the best you've
dressed on the show I'm proud of you man
dude I look like you got you dig a
rocket ship to somebody's dick don't
touch me don't frickin get any our
inability on my beautiful suit what I'm
saying is if friend okay dude call me
would you [ __ ] oh dude if you're woody
apply bro that is prettier dude your
teeth bro you ain't no mahogany dog
that's for damn sure you're something
you're that IKEA would do the kind of
[ __ ] you actually got cut from Star Trek
didn't make this bar a bar star trash
they're like I want your other movie and
I'm like okay I wanna be your star tree
so uh that's good less gay okay whatever
man-- did if you pulled me over dude I
would put the cuffs on you bro
that's for sure I would tase you dude
cuff me up oh wow leave me up bro you
got a partner what are you doing up here
in the air and space boy
what's cat cats just uh skeleton dead on
the inside
yeah well she's into witchcraft
yeah yeah you look nice today okay you
actually look nice as a skeleton I think
Derrick why don't you say something nice
one okay she feels better on the inside
she doesn't have an inside Derrick be
respectful Kat has a black heart yeah
dark heart dude the dark hearts dark
hearts the dark cards tour I love my
suit because this uh has these footies
in it that are real soft don't squeeze
my feet bro man adult yeah mine came
with some cool footage too Oh some off
like Nikes damn that's cool woody
Woody's a [ __ ] hike boy
we're gonna pick up a unique male
audience this time yeah we look like the
worst [ __ ] furries I've ever seen man
bro you look like some guy that tries to
frickin Raja rafts at a rodeo you put
Derrick in the Midlands have big hold oh
I guess we'll call that a pickle pickles
gonna stand
pickles got that's a lot of pink man
these pickles they say orange is the new
pickle where did you get that man okay
okay I don't like that cats like our new
ah designer condom yeah she is what Nazi
put these [ __ ] candy corns on the
table that is some terrible candy burn
involved they were suppository that's
why I think they're so bad he's had
about 19 oh yeah like man my butt is
like mine I can't even I came really I
came rod another one of these little
butt shuttles Mike that's a candy corn
bra
he put 200 them in the microwave is like
man they won't pop
I never got it you're crazy
I'm not terrible Vernon's the kind of
guy that just eats the white top off of
a candy corn and says I've had too much
I think I've had my [ __ ]
[Laughter]
well that's crazy look man do you know
mirror broke a mirror of what town yeah
why you'll see what cuz I'm [ __ ]
they're gonna do for me dude
I don't know raise the taxes did you out
here mine man where's like all you look
like [ __ ] you should raise the taxes
unbelievable man
Halloween episode yes is yeah Halloween
ma'am happy Halloween give you got big
planes you trick-or-treating took my son
last night to some like weird pumpkin
patch thing for you or they caught they
probably call it closed because
Halloween's tonight no no you don't go
on Halloween I mean you could but but
you'll see thousands of families if you
go out on Halloween burglar no no we're
in the night before you get all the good
candy be really what are you doing here
trick-or-treat just [ __ ] give us the
candy
just give me that bedroom set somebody
gave me their remote control one time my
dad took us on the wrong hell yeah
remote control had just come out man
people were fired up it's a pretty cool
gift what do you think was nice dude I
remember as a kid we used to uh least to
use pillowcases we get so much candy
weaves pillowcases Oh beautiful you
don't see kids with that today mm-hmm
you know it's a urban myth you remember
how my dude let's don't [ __ ] you
don't like the urban part what is don't
say Derek an urban myth dude know that
no but it is an urban I believe in you
Derek it's the urban no you're always on
time in our hearts man you know what I
mean that but don't call man urban myth
no this is a real goddess dude you know
how parents used to check for razor
blades and candy mm-hmm that that you
know does all make that will no one put
razor blades in candles I'll make
believe really yeah I was like it put
like scaring everybody
but that
never happened dude oh no that's happen
eventually
my nephew found a razor scooter in his
almond joy yeah so he's [ __ ] a bit
into it dude and buggin
almost broke his jaw one of the handles
probably the only joy oh you got to
really get in there to find the home and
you almost have to use your tongue where
they get these baby almonds
give me some fat almonds dude yeah give
me that [ __ ] middle-school almond boy
yeah I like an almond that's you know
spend a couple of days in the clink you
know yeah like that almond that's a
little jacked up his [ __ ] stamp about
seven years yeah that post an almond
he's gone with a series of almonds
they're beautiful almonds yeah I don't
have a pack of Derek's beautiful almonds
Derek's almonds Derek's nuts
Pierce nuts nope not having to be up
slow oh my god do this hat is just wild
dude yeah you know what happened if you
rolled into the Abbey tonight dressed
like that oh yeah now Oh make me scared
but I like a piece of gym equipment
those get boys would be on me like a
cowboy bro Oh
in a dog park Oh the only chew toy some
big guy running back and they gots whoa
yeah dogs get front end back people are
eating out of both end of the trough man
yeah yeah this like you dry no
silverware no silver you know Biff no
bibs dude brendan has a lot of bibs a
bit you see my kind of guy
dude if he's gonna drive in it's raining
out he puts a bib on I can't wait
again you're a cowboy dude super cowboy
Oh City bro Key West Florida [ __ ]
tottingham bro you look like you were
gonna trap house [ __ ] haunted house
today it's going bad plus like here is
this man me at the mall
unbeliev what prison system on you work
in right why are your wings even
depressed hey man I need a new Buzz
Lightyear this one's super say I'm like
buzz like modernity all right yeah this
is what cross street and get some meat I
feel like I'm like Buzz Light month fro
Buzz Light life happy Halloween guys
yeah thank you guys for sticking with us
this long on this show man I don't know
what this shows about but I don't either
but I'll tell we catch a case right now
stand up in this woody suit apparently
there's a that ain't function mr. Potato
Head my pants ain't that slinky machine
know what kind of what do you got a dick
caught him in the soup bro and when I
walk through the office it was alarming
really yeah man you said one kids now
start watering like this howdy partner
you see something like speak up now your
buddy kept on keepin on bro kid yeah I'm
at man I'm in man small man yeah he was
smaller he's just smaller
yeah dude print went to reach for his
gun and just got an erection
[Laughter]
dude you're like a heads up bro you're
Lassiter's peaked out of your buttocks
bro you got a died man man dad hmm cold
wind hits this thing's gonna rip right
off yeah I was like you've been smoking
those morrow buzz got the black lung
blop you've been heavy year for bugs
[Laughter]
give me the space brother like buzz
didn't [ __ ] make to make season four
huh this sad sad Eman give me the space
guy
you look like NASA bro heavy on the ass
you're taking me to space dude we're
gonna end up in Uranus space cowboys but
brilliant kind of guy who [ __ ] goes
to space just to sit on a Saturn's rings
dude hey I'm hanging my legs off the
ring guys well good to see you man you
too brother
keep touching him touching me especially
the skeleton hand still no plan for
Halloween I don't know man dressed up as
a pirate
just randomly yeah oh I saw that on
Instagram and you did
is that real facial errors that's not he
grew that out I told him it's a you know
see Halloween's coming and you're gonna
have to pirates only have beards you
know he emailed me and asked me if yeah
if you're legally allowed to go
door-to-door Nell's neighbor brought I
said yes I said yes you are I looked up
one stranger-danger you're not on there
I'm not on there have you ever looked
that up oh yeah you won't want to live
in you air dude when I was growing up
pedophiles had to go door to door and
say hey buddy you know how I work I live
in the neighborhood you know I'm just
letting you know I live in the
neighborhood that was a state law and
all our parents were single parents so
like my mom would be at work we'd have
these dudes come to the door and like
hey I'm Jonathan you know just letting
you know I moved into the neighborhood
and I'm a pedophile you know who'd like
war mommy at home you know but come back
later yeah
come back later Jonathan she makes a
mean apple pie yeah come play Sega with
us yeah you know what once just come in
right now now I think it what are you
doing Jonathan make sure you know you
got a stepdad yeah yeah yeah he's had a
shady history but seems to be doing
better yeah I don't know man we used to
play kickball with pedophiles that when
I was growing up they're [ __ ] good at
kickball man well some of them are
but once you know they're a pedophile
the game's over you know it's like roll
that ball Ronnie ain't getting this ass
bro you know roll that ball dude here's
the thing with pedophiles did you play
crazy kickball we could kick it and run
either that way or that way first or
third oh my god crazy pedophile kickball
yes really in Denver bros pedophiles
were good we're good
they were always brought the little
orange slices halftime was lit damn dude
you definitely you look like one a row
you look I got Eclair that Romeo Crennel
had for breakfast you look like you've
been through some things but are you
doing okay I'm fantastic who are you
again what costume is it dude
I'm woody and you're buzz light gear
never heard of either one of them okay
so I don't know what you are dude it is
just really alarming dude you just think
you're an astronaut do you look like
Dallas a returners club dude like
somebody got a refund yeah look like
you're going and threes on the stuff
brah no Mira I can't see my outfit dude
no you look warm you look sweet dude the
wings are kind of heavy though yeah
they're super depressed wings yeah no I
mean it was like heavy on my back man I
just don't want to I may need to have it
like a Jamba Juice or something to get
through the episode so whoa dude I'm
trying to get them lit bro they're not
lit up well no they are about just
trying to well this is like uh I think
those lights make it heavier I feel like
just wanted Chin's parents is probably
what they probably where I feel like
it's how do you get a chin man and they
just can't get back to where they were
going yeah stranded stranded here at
King in the sting let's rock dude and
what is this first of all things are
going downhill if there's a Roach trap
on the desk so that's alarming so it has
them explained to do anyone wanna mr.
pickle cat yeah girl dark heart yeah cat
you're low on calcium it looks like huh
with us that old sternum game
cats got that sternum aa little x-ray
game over the Hokies just look at the
Famers on that kitten did I went to an
ultrasound for my son that's gonna be
born in about four weeks
mmm this is to i-19 he look like using
the next [ __ ] conjuring you should
it's only black and white and you just
see eyes you see these dark eyes and
just like almost a ghost figure really
yeah man
scary [ __ ] and what um it's a boy you
said it's a young man Wow
cuz I tell you the one thing we did not
mistake can only see you get the dick on
them that piece huh yeah I don't look at
kids dicks even if it's inside of my
wife's body and I don't have a wife
dude you couldn't miss it you couldn't
miss this I went oh is that a tail am i
giving birth to a lizard
is that a [ __ ] t-rex the doctor went
that's a dick Jesus I know dude and it's
not a dick until they're like 15 or
something Brendan it's just a wiener
nope
wow that's fair Oh here's the thing so
you don't have kids you don't know this
can't call it a wiener you can't nope
cuz when you call it Wiener like cute
names that's what pedophiles caught let
me get the kids you always keep it penis
you have to i think somebody made that
up and told you that what did you guys
do to where there are a lot of
pedophiles in you guys in neighborhoods
in the different environments i didn't
look that up until I was probably in
high school and I realized I live with a
lot of pedophile
hey man to lady know it mmm did you guys
have-have the scare on your neighborhood
there was always a pedophile Halloween
non Halloween didn't matter always had a
van we'd always have to warn us about
what color van don't pay attention to
the van don't don't stop at the van now
did I go in there cuz he had Cadbury
eggs maybe when we tried it out over a
guy called a good deal
yeah Bernie ahem overeasy Brens the only
person that's ever made a Cadbury egg
omlet some kids thought it was abuse I
was a good trade I used a full pack
we're sending told that egg Joe no
you're all right man I don't know if I
am Derek now in the urban communities
are a lot of pedophiles or what is that
because it yeah my mom worked at a
nursing home she's like an administrator
so a lot of those guys were pedophiles
really we're trying to lure me to the
a lot of really yeah oh man uh hold on
are they pedophiles are just old dudes
looking for a friend yeah you know I
never let it get far enough to find out
there's one of them talk sports with you
but you thought they were trying to
freaking touch your wee-wee true I was
six interesting to talk supports the
six-year-old but you have yeah you know
your sports I do you think little
cucumber Derek knows about frickin Mark
McGwire's bra no six years old you don't
know about all that
now do you think that these men were
actual PDF files or do you think that
they um they were just like they would
touch anybody if they were man or woman
they were just wanting somebody around
that was kind of one to warm bodies yeah
talk to talk to you though I think for
sexual it felt sexual I remember one
time a guy was like come here come in
the room I got something to show you he
was really old and I was like all right
and then my mom came and yelled at all
my hey you're not gonna be keep doing
this Daniel you know but also your mom
quit bringing the little guy around
trying to [ __ ] them every day quit
bringing them around they're not trying
to [ __ ] him Brendon these are senior
citizen men yeah okay they're doing the
best they can a lot of more in different
Wars you yeah maybe they're trying to
share their applesauce with you yeah
Vietnam stories touch you yeah but not
trying to [ __ ] him
it could be just touch him pet him touch
his body look you look like it yeah
beautiful kids see what kind of man have
to see the pictures but the thing is
again - your mom quit bringing D to work
you no good bringing up the school you
have to see the pictures I see the
pictures are you getting to say kids
cute I've seen some ugly kids but you're
an officer of the law brah that's right
bro work hard for work [ __ ] hard look
at you you smile you just go to Mars and
tough there's life there I'm just gonna
go up there be happy there's nobody
around just stay no no one's here I just
stay I bet your mace whenever you press
it it's just some guy just whisper knew
another guy
you out of your mind I bet your cuffs
are made out of [ __ ] cheese was you
just spray cheeses are on each one of
their wrists you don't know what's going
on what the [ __ ] never worked a day in
your life is [ __ ] cop no I can't believe
in the freedom buzz lightyear in the
Chinese community cat if you're Chinese
I'm not sure but thank you oh you do
have some Chinese yes she does bring a
lot of pedophiles in China are there
though I don't think there are I don't
think it's as much of an Asian thing I
know it's a white thing and I know it
happens sometimes in the black community
you know porno Derrick people get a
little handsy yeah a lot of white guys
growing up would pull up in the vans to
try to kidnap Asian kids but as we got
older they didn't want us as much mmm I
wonder why I could see that over there
Cuba as you get old they're super cute
yeah
yeah yeah go one or two ways maybe you
get real cute or you age like fruit mmm
oh yeah buddy mine had a stem sprout out
of his back and he's about 11 years old
he's from the Xiang yang province
definitely those good a lot of fruit
aging okay once again we've ruined
people's lives happy Halloween guys
nothing scarier than listening to this
um but we're grateful you guys are here
with us today be safe out there on the
streets man trick-or-treating
door-to-door it's real hustle like
you're gonna help dude you might be my
kid to be out there nam be dressed as
the boogeyman from Nightmare Before
Christmas but you make a move now so you
touched my kid I'm [ __ ] its own but
the only person touching your kid is you
dude you got to go look at that outfit
man I gotta get a merit dude you got to
look at yours dude bro you need to get a
mayor okay you need to get go to the
mayor of your town and asking what you
look like cuz you can't be living like
this we got pickle we got a little
debate club boys first we have Ashley
Ashley from Columbus sup guys hope
you're having a great day I'm coming to
you from Columbus Ohio with a debate
club question for you really quick I
just want to say that I met Brendan and
Derek at the Pittsburgh improv the other
day it was
really nice meeting you both you guys
both killed it and you're both really
sweet and nice so I want to say thanks
for making my weekend so good no problem
I already told Derek this but if you
guys just had mean a white girl for
culture corner which I think you do let
me know yeah enough why just do in
Cleveland the other day and I was really
upset about it I ended up having an exam
that following day so I couldn't be oh
it's okay
memory so back to the debate club
question it's October its quote-unquote
spooky season so here's your question
are ghosts real or are they not real
personally I don't know and I don't know
if I want to know the answer let me know
what you guys thinking thank you young
lady for uh I'm sorry that um you
couldn't make it to my show um is ghosts
real but she doesn't know she wants to
know the answer so I don't if I want to
tell her either I don't know if she can
handle it dude one time my friend died
and uh and then that night I thought
that he was there and I never felt like
somebody was there like in your bed
no outside on the porch he's just
chilling us on the porch he was trying
to get in but he didn't have any hands
mmm now do you think it was a post mates
and you forgot about it no no this was
before post mates about three years
before posted in a rural area where post
mates went out there somebody's gonna
probably gun them down that's fair so
you know dive post mates huh how about
those post mates I go into the hood like
SEAL Team six yeah dude plug for a
[ __ ] batch of taquito deliver a hot
pizza dodged some bullets real Americans
oh dude and by the time you get there
the pizzas just warm cause of all the
bullets in it yeah cheese a little
shuffled up cuz he's running so far uh
all right ghost we'll listen I'll say
this and this is well-documented I was
on a ghost adventure show with zak
bagans mm-hmm now I'm not positive we
found that Ghost pretty sure we found it
goes I was scared shitless Oh shitless I
was so scared
mmm and ever since then I believe in
ghosts well I think ghosts have to be
real because I think
there's something you know a lot of
times I feel a spirit inside of me that
is separate from my body it's like my
body is just kind of like a bus and the
spirit is like riding around in this bus
so I think if you die then the spirit
gets loose and then it can sometime that
can be around it's an under can't I
think some of that's depending upon
whether and some of that's depending
upon you know like rent control all that
kind of [ __ ] so you probably I'm not
gonna tell you anymore
I think no you don't can't handle it
yeah I don't think do you believe in
ghosts II not at all no do you believe
in afterlife yeah yeah you better
believe in a damn afterlife but you
won't believe in ghosts I don't think
people die and they hang out on earth
cutting light switches on why not this
mainly they work for Cliquot maybe they
work for the power company if they're
ghosts you know why they [ __ ] like
turn on lights and push it over certain
like bumping emissions all they can do
what if those are your only tricks do
what you were shitty David Blaine that's
all the ghost is my god is a shitty
David Blaine I'm a wiggle this chain
over here I'm gonna do these lights I'm
a [ __ ] touch you know Samuels [ __ ]
neck
that's it brought it all yeah I'm gonna
whisper and Brendan there at night like
that's what I'm doing man
you believe in an afterlife but not
gonna happen
what do you mean nothing delights your
show out Derek losing all of our black
audience by not believing in heaven and
aren't you a fan of the Kanye West album
and you don't think there's go sunday
service man is what I'm saying if
Congress if you don't think Kanye's
going to heaven dude he's the [ __ ]
black Tesla bro okay
Johnny's going to having people out here
milling around and [ __ ] I don't know if
he is huh nice but he's brave bro Kanye
he's brave and crazy he's like brave II
crazy cat what do you think you guys
have ghosts in your community or
something what's going on
you shouldn't have tons of go I could
see that because Asians never truly die
that's the thing Wow guys kind the ones
that started the whole ghost rumors know
these not a rumor yeah they did you you
believe in ghost cat yep but I don't
know if all races it's just camera as a
ghost I could [ __ ] see
Greece's become ghosts that's the thing
I think only some races then become
ghosts some of them just kind of go to
heaven or hell or maybe somewhere else
believe that I think all races go you
know I already like a little Asian ghost
I think would be kind of cute you know
hey booboo that's a Latino goes eh I'm
from Ecuador boo-boo
I'm hiding
I think papi mi ting overeater
apparently your ghost is super gay he's
my gay man this is how we sound you know
I have a wife you heard him to that oh
just playing just playing homeboy
I got 11 Curie we're all goes over here
there's a chili in my ass
what bro I have a wiping geez mundane
you hear about my [ __ ] is that you bros
a different goes up gay can't be more
obvious homes stuff my jalapeno chili
uh-huh you're not even gay bro it's that
guy throwing like a tight suit man you
might be right bro you're not even a cop
bro you're in a [ __ ] van right now
[Laughter]
well I don't do improv that's why I
can't go so we got one out of two
believe in ghosts
well ghost Hanzhong tat believe in
ghosts Derek doesn't but he believes in
Kanye West is a afterlife and you're
kind of I believe in ghosts man
yeah I grew up in there's a lot of
haunting a lot of people haunted dude
they had a guy who impersonated a ghost
in our town and haunted a Ramada and the
police busted him driving a Ford Ranger
[ __ ] yeah dude Dodge Ram now there's a
lot of witchcraft in New Orleans huh
there's some [ __ ] [ __ ] and I'm
[ __ ] keeping it together
that there's also just some [ __ ] that
have dreadlocks but just by but that's
DeAndre Hopkins that you're talking
about dude oh you might be right yeah
that he got his arm caught in his hair
dude titty cap are you trying to call
Rick without interference nothing feet
long I'm all about everybody having long
hair dude I got it but at a certain
point well you kind of got you got here
come the second down marker the other
day kept on keepin on bro
but we had an assistant coach it thought
the guy had me kidnapped in his hair a
nutritionist brother they found under
one of his sideburns I'm just saying
it's getting intense DeAndre um but good
luck with ghost girl hopefully it works
out continue to what else you got
we got 57% went with ghosts are real yep
mmm that's fair have you ever seen any
ghost activity at the Comedy Store Thea
have you ever seen anything weird go
down there write some dark vibes there
I've seen a lot of people run the light
I've seen a lot of bad [ __ ] comedy
including some of my own that wasn't
good so I've seen a lot of us I'll tell
you this you get haunted by some bad
sets I'll say that you're a bad set up
there that [ __ ] don't want you that [ __ ]
will haunt you man oh let's get into
something else too have any other
Halloweeny stuff oh yeah we got a up
next we got mr. Austin from Owensboro
Kentucky who owensboro really dressed up
as Lucy you know that Brendan you look
like that al Qaeda Isis got a guy killed
put in Whiteface
Bobby Lee or Chris D'Elia let me know
Fang Fang blood blood Peng Fang blood
blood bro who's the big guy with the red
beard that does the [ __ ] it's delicious
how's it going Seth Rogen Action Bronson
that's who that's a great Halloween
outfit sir I like that Action Bronson
yeah you got to make a suit good dude
Bobby Lee Oh Chris this is easy every
Asian dies first in their horror movies
just the way I think I'm if it's black
or Asian they die first ago what they
come back but a lot of black guys are
making it to the end of movies now
yeah you have to the whole yeah with
like sides change yeah looking I think a
lot of black guys I think would be at
the end of movies now mmm you see a lot
more black guys with sword fighting
skills a lot more diverse type of skills
that's why I like white man can't jump
remember that oh yeah Woody Harrelson
the white guy trying to fit in he's the
one who got broke at the end you know
it's kind of role reversal I love that
movie dude I like um what movie do our
light mm-hmm have you seen Incredibles
one great moving crevel too is very
boring yeah you're seeing tango and cash
no we look like tango and Bosch what
else we got yeah I'm tango dude yeah
I'll bet you look like somebody I'll
bash these nuts in your mouth there's a
snake in my boot
you boys crazy you mispronounce but dude
and second of all do you make a [ __ ]
deal getting a pinata bro okay nine kids
would beat the [ __ ] out of with a stick
to get a [ __ ] sugar out of Chris
Chris why can't I think Bobby Lee is
gonna die first but I think he'll find a
way back and that's how he defeats Chris
you know Chris is the guy he thinks
gonna win in it and then he doesn't you
know that he has that hero vibe but I
think Bobby's that tricky little [ __ ]
scallop that comes back in the end and
you don't think he's hanging off the
side of your boat and he is you know
he's that uh I like that movie like Saul
like the new Saul I think Chris Rock is
directing it is he yeah yeah Wow
if Bobby were in it might have made that
up I can't see Bobby I could see Bobby
inside but now he's gonna die early you
didn't like to do that much stuff so if
he has to even be on set more than an
hour and a half he's gonna to make you
work for a whole motion picture so it's
like died early yeah what else you got
we got 70% went with mr. Bobby Lee as
well that's just something wrong science
support the podcast here's an ad look
sometimes I want to you know I want
something to eat man and I'm just so
sick of just eating cereal dude not
caring about myself oh dude I'm glad you
said that
because now there's hellofresh they make
cooking delicious at home alright and
you don't have to be Wolfgang Puck's to
do all this I'm talking step-by-step
recipes of pre-measured ingredients so
all you open it get your cook on dude
get your cook on yeah imagine having a
spatula imagine having a meal you can
have all of that man yeah and there's
some for everyone whether you're a loner
whether you got a family
they got calorie smart vegetarian fun
menu series like the Hall of Fame and
craft burgers hellofresh has more
five-star recipes than any other meal
kit here you dude probably the only
thing you've ever cooked up dude is a
bunch of [ __ ] bad answers on a test
bro here's what I'm saying is hellofresh
has all kind of stuff imagine a box of
magic [ __ ] shows up at your house and
next thing you know your fat little
family is [ __ ] mugging down a mean
set of sweet pork chops yeah dude
or instead of mashing the potatoes with
your tears you do it with your buddies
now with yellow fresh you can mash them
between here freaking cousin's tits dude
these are family meals okay this is
where a family gets together and cracks
open a box of fresh goods yes you're a
sausage between you and your mom
delicious flexible easy to change your
delivery days food preferences and skip
a week whenever you need and right now
you guys you guys I'm gonna use guys you
get $80 off your first month of
hellofresh go to hellofresh comm slash
cats 80 and enter cats 80 yup it's a
great way to get a present for somebody
you don't know what to get him get him
hell are fresh let them try a new
experience in the kitchen think about
everyone has to eat yep it's like it's
really great get eighty dollars off your
first month of hello fresh go-to hello
fresh calm slash cats a tea time to buy
feel more pants ah dude if you're a
homeowner you know tough it is what I
call me bro homeowner whoa dude I know I
think you think it's something else dude
now you own homes dude oh yeah if your
rates have crept up over the years yet
start seeing about replacing your policy
man yeah how to start doing it in the
old days maybe you get a new home if
you're if you're if your joint was
haunted
you know where if you are if you want
won the lottery yeah if you were if you
are if they had a fire in the house if
your grandmama passed away you got her
busted ass crib
listen vault cg I got a bunch of old
pictures on the wall and everybody has
bad haircuts yeah sweaters listen balls
jeans so Danny they got a lot of gerbils
in the walls bra or rat yeah start by
answering a few quick questions so the
team can get to know you and your
property the pasta juice will help you
to compare your policy against more than
ten other insurance companies you have
to make sure you get the best home
insurance possible yeah now policy
genius is something it used to be I
didn't yet it call your step daddy or
call your grandfather so how do i how do
I figure this out what do I do now we're
just telling you you take care of
yourself you prepare you plan ahead dude
get her you know what I'm saying you
don't stand out in the rain without a
frickin policy yeah be a grown-up you
can get started on your smart phone
right now Paul see genius the easy way
to compare and buy home insurance yep
whether you need home insurance for a
new place you just want to reshape your
current policy they can do both policy
genius the easy way to compare and buy
home insurance Paul to genius.com
someone's got to pay for Brennan's
coffee habit this is David from New
Zealand oh good eye Kiwi lads it's your
boy David gank hanging it down here in
New Zealand got a special Halloween
debate club for you gentlemen what was
better heading that trick or treat
madness and you're a young chap getting
them sugary snacks causing some mischief
or hidden into them at adult Halloween
parties trying to find them different
sort of snacks I'm talking eight minutes
that [ __ ] nurse in the corner you know
what I'm saying no wait we got it you
guys appreciate the work Gang Gang
buzz-buzz appreciates what work are we
doing actually this is a questionable
work tanka David could be the devil's
work sometimes yeah thank you David
- trick or treat his kid was so fun how
many parties bum me out a little bit I
mean yeah we're sucking in a [ __ ]
because there's reason to do it also did
you were you with a sexy costume guy
were you the the more serious costume
guy you know I'm saying some guys took
it too serious I am I got a friend man
every year he planet months out the full
makeup you know I I'm gonna has a big
baby for multiple years in college and
man that diaper didn't stay on long I'll
say that much damn couple of brewskis
diaper gets lose brewski he sounds like
a nice guy
Brandon [ __ ] serving that butt up to
polish here's what I'm saying dude I
think I don't even know what I'm about
to say neither remember calling what was
this question this guy wants to
Halloween parties parties are great I'm
treating in Charleston South Carolina
I'm one time I made out with four
ladybugs in a night dude which is pretty
cool they shave it loose a buddy of mine
named Barry one time put um
dress up like an airplane and put real
jet fuel in the back of his legs and
burn [ __ ] holes into his skin oh yeah
so we had to go to the emergency room
dude pretty girl out for it you can go
to any other room and it's just like hey
I'm probably gonna be okay and then they
have an emergency room and if you go
there it's like hurrah
yeah yeah so he went there right there
um yeah between other kids you go along
I used to love that man I win I was just
amazed now at the amount of candy that
kids can eat like now if I have like
three four pieces of candy or if I have
like you know forearm ice cream
sandwiches at night or something the
third and fourth one I can't even taste
that much because so much sugar is
already logged into me yeah my tongue
just goes numb too oh and you were a kid
you could do dude I would open up reisi
cups and put sweet tarts in them lay
some with [ __ ] sweet dogs and then
eat those [ __ ] and make my sister
[ __ ] eat him dude her she wasn't
going to bed that little [ __ ] keep
touching me bro like yeah dude keep
lacing kids candy bro hey man
Razor scooter I'm unhappy [ __ ]
Cinnabon that's all positive but what do
you guys think over there let's hit this
culture corner man I'm tired I've just
been being so white over here
trick-or-treating as a kid Andy you guys
who was it scary and some of your
neighborhoods there I lived in a good
neighborhood man went to like private
school okay we gotta get
yeah you're getting mixed signals Aaron
okay we gotta make it simple man this is
Hollywood Derrick you got to keep it
easy for these people but you did go
trick-or-treating in the nice
neighborhood yeah we did - we would go
over to a nice that was always you got a
trick-or-treat up yes you go to the
nicer neighborhood I don't know where
you're at
you still always go to nicer
neighborhoods I used to have some dope
costume oh dude I one time I went as
wd-40 didn't had my whole [ __ ] face
and everything sprayed with wd-40 and it
smells good my maracas that stuff smells
I do enjoy that smell
god it's [ __ ] good I went as a French
robot one year my mom made me a robot
costume then I grabbed our croissants
from Costco and gave him out to the kids
my mom was pissed yeah ten kids got that
hot croissant though we had hot I even
had a little mustache French robot best
costume I've ever had
my brothers the ninja we have some great
mom mom nice make all her costumes dude
really yeah oh really yeah wow I'm made
of bro my mom is still a black sheet or
me every year well that's the black
sheet of the family on yeah she just
show a black sheet and what what were
you supposed to be if a black ghost well
there are no bad ghosts you know they're
always right and you know they're always
white some of them are black you know
you don't see him as much because you
them in a different community yeah yeah
I don't see color
well yeah was your best Halloween outfit
um I don't remember I didn't I used to
rewear my older cousins hand-me-down so
it's whatever she wore the year before I
would then get a traditional garb
Brendan yeah I would go as a Chinese
lady every single year different version
I love that have a lantern or something
around like a Geisha no just a random
Chinese woman they're like fisherwoman
Express from Vietnam and then we just go
around I'd carry chopsticks or some [ __ ]
would you wow I feel like that's a
terabyte nobody called me out for any of
it they're just like Oh adorable like lo
Asian girl you're the cutest yeah I was
a kid cat oh yeah not have to see
pictures when I was young if somebody
came to our door and they were a
different ethnicity that was a costume
was like you know cuz it was
so rare I was like oh damn bro my
daddy's a Mexican yeah Eduardo Eduardo
is here my god come down great costume
Eduardo yeah it was the summer though
yeah well what they want to know they
say yes they want us at their party no
no they just want to know if you like to
eat Rena's kid all [ __ ] day
listen grown adults dressing up taking
to [ __ ] too serious just not for me man
how many parties yeah and you can't keep
up with that man I've been involved in
some things that I probably shouldn't
have been involved in and Halloween you
got a really you got a plan ahead if you
want to look nice but you also want a
costume it's kind of feasible you know
you can like navigate in do we used to
do make that pubic hair mustache and cut
your pubic hair off and make a mustache
with a little bit of honey up above your
lip that's really disturbing there you
know very disturbing really yeah man
make that [ __ ] baby curtain up there
no I get it that is very disturbing
I don't think so guy who puts vegetables
in his butt yeah I don't know man mr.
McGregor let's keep this thing moving
man 56% way with trick-or-treating thank
you yeah thank you
up next this is rocky Kendall this is
big rocky no one's gonna dress up now
about these nice chops
oh he's what he's super dude what's up
there what's up Brandon I got a debate
club for you guys with Halloween coming
up I've been watching a lot of classic
horror movies and in my mind the most
iconic like movie serial killers would
be like Jason Freddy Krueger Mike Myers
and Leatherface and my question for you
guys is if those guys decided to just
have an all-out brawl in a cage who do
you think is coming out on top now that
being said this is just a straight-up
fight so Freddy Kruger can't kill
anybody in their dream Wow so this is
just Freddy Krueger throwing hands with
that glove now so uh let me know what
you guys think and who would win Gang
Gang Gang man is this guy
this from the Dharma Initiative where's
this guy sending this video from because
what's going on the background there is
a whale at this guy's door dude you can
hear sonar you can hear it I'd be on a
boat yeah yeah you might be on a vessel
that's about to go down so this is this
could be a ghost
yes that could be a ghost because you'd
be send this from the Titanic I'll say
this who's Leatherface you mean Ron
White I don't remember him uh well Texas
Chainsaw that dude was just it's a Royal
Rumble I'll tell you right now Fred Egon
has asked what phrase just a
malnourished older dude who got burned
in a fire yeah if you can't kill you in
his dreams he just said some dude off
Third Street ain't [ __ ] yeah people are
gonna think he's a pepperoni sales and
people get them confused as well these
days people me remember Freddy Krueger
that I think it's a guy trying to sell a
pizza cuz he kind of looks like one cell
string cheese people are going to I
think if you go Michael Myers that
dude's got that haunty sort of thing
Michael Myers was kind of just like kind
of like a um a little bit of like a gay
Jason I think in a lot of ways the Jason
came with the hockey he came with the
machete and then he got Mike showing up
with this [ __ ] little silverware and
the one piece yeah the one piece like
that rocking hot girl summer yeah that
hot girl [ __ ] summer outfit look he
does--like swaggy yeah he looks Maggie
but he looks like he's gonna [ __ ] be
really angry while he like changes your
oil
whereas Jason v's bro that big daddy
that dirt dog bad dude bro that dudes
gonna remodel your skeleton you know
what I'm saying
yeah I [ __ ] with Jason Jason all day
Royal Rumble and [ __ ] Leatherface get up
yeah somebody make a purse out of that
little Muppet yeah dude here's what I'm
saying is they got if anybody that plays
hockey with a machete is probably gonna
win you know uh but first Isle first
team All GQ I'm gonna Mike Myers and
that leak is that me we have the same
here I have a onesie like that Mike
Myers yeah yeah you do look similar
Mike Myers looks like a sashimi chef at
like Edie Bev
or something or one of those restaurants
where they're real angry at you I'm
going Jason all [ __ ] I'm going Jason
all day look at that listen I don't know
who's gonna win I think Jason and Mike
Myers might have a real struggle City
there but say one thing I do know
Freddie ain't winning [ __ ] and
Leatherface somebody make a wallet out
of that a little [ __ ] facebooking
yeah dude any you know I'm saying Fendi
face broad get out of here with leather
a pair of nuts yeah where's your nuts at
[ __ ] that that is my favorite scary
movie though yeah takes chainsaw
I don't watch all that you don't like
that stuff scares you no didn't scare me
at us I don't like to you it's just like
appropriation of chainsaws appropriation
of Texans really takes chainsawed of it
yeah it's really you want good chainsaw
and go up to go to Michigan you know
Western Alaska yeah go to Alaska dude
yeah Texas they're not doing that much
with chainsaws no so it's just it's
appropriation again Jason for the win by
the way Jason for the win
32 percent Freddy Krueger 31 percent
Jason Jamie's coming in third was Mike
and then coming in last was old
Leatherface yeah I love the phrase just
a [ __ ] idiot
Leatherface damn near killed him dude
I'm out what else we got
we're gonna go a little clown my hand
boys okay now these are my seasonal
hounds cuz I want to see some Halloween
house put some [ __ ] horns on a howl
or something dude yeah I want to see
haunt my aunt dude I want to see you
better I always see a clown in blackface
let's go hear em buzz buzz knees
laughter cigars bro it's the Black Lung
laughs the Cubans pop a first this is
Remy oh my god Remy's up furry if I've
ever seen one
Remy's book been at uh apparently EDC
all weekend yeah still licking his face
yeah Remy just did a stint in [ __ ]
Vegas
yeah roulette shot eyes Remy looks like
an auditor odd dog if carrot top was the
driver of the sled
uh Remmy's been through some stuff huh
yeah every one of Jeremy pivens [ __ ]
buddies or a girl breakin a fire claim
rémi bloodshot eye Remi needs sleep
yeah bro Remi need to nap and take the
[ __ ] wig off
yeah Remi looks like he was an oil spill
and kind of liked it you know he looks
like the kind of dog that'll take a
couple of couple tabs X and jump in an
oil spill yeah Remi seems like he's
coming down off the X and super
depressed yeah Remy's been at Coachella
all weekend yeah and first of all
dressed up like a unicorn did it means a
lot of horses are coming at you with
them big wieners brother dude don't keep
touching me session time horizonte's me
all I know is Remi needs a break yeah
what else do we know about Remi anything
we don't know anything much about Remi
other than he's a unicorn and uh the
owners came to your show and you told
the lady that you had a mullet above
your dick I did that's what you said
well I mean she was also a gang gang
buzz-buzz Yeah right but if she's also
peddling these types of animals you know
who meant what kind of animals mate to
make this little Remi I don't know what
kind of dogs it's a good point
I didn't say
this looks like this looks like a my
like a mouse he would find in avicii's
house you know this thing looks like
it's been through some stuff yeah it's
[ __ ] the unicorn yeah this looks like
a oven mitt it Diplo's you know this
looks like it's like a stuffed toy of
Steve Aoki's house this thing looks like
it's been a sex slave somewhere maybe on
Saturn or something this looks like
Brendan's the sheriff this looks like
his little fricken deputy right yeah
that's my house that's my canine get
REME go and sniff that x out that x out
thank you for sending this dog in it
looks like a beautiful animal I think
you definitely have to get it uh some
vitamin B injectables though it needs
some b12 fast yeah so it needs a IV no
next we got Paisley and arrow
Paisley ripping that king in the sting
like huh okay buzz buzz that is me and
Thea that's me on the right and CEO
status [ __ ] on the left is that is that
two bees though now I love these costume
now this is beautiful animal hell yeah
beautiful animal and on the left looks
like seeing some [ __ ] this beautiful
animal is right here but the one on the
left is one of them definitely be have
the wings but one of them got just the
stripes one just has a turtleneck on
it's two bees
those two bees no buzz buzz double buzz
oh that one looks like a two definitely
catch a frisbee uh you know or catch a
couple steak medallions or something you
know one of the left looks like you eat
all is honey well yeah the one on the
left he's sad because he's blind in one
eye after being attacked by a 90-pound
dog oh that's me that's me
that always been some [ __ ] damn where
the dog took his eye out and the other
ones master that was just blinding
enough what does it say about the other
one here oh it says the other one
struggled in school and also makes a lot
of poor dietary choices
oh that's Brendon that's the Brendon one
that's us dude that's us man good to see
you
buzz-buzz dude nice to know we'll be
reincarnated in some
happy home looks like a beautiful area
it doesn't make a nice little home thank
you for sending in paisley an arrow dem
dogs right there dude up next we got
this one's awesome this is miss Tootie
pinch damn mmm seems like she's gonna
yell at me to get a pumpkin spice latte
ooh look at the pumpkin spice body on
that thing huh
and that hound is bodied oh those
[ __ ] little thought feelers has
little arms dude yeah I think looks like
when you get a cheap uh chicken wing and
that you know if you get a buffalo wild
wings yeah if you get that [ __ ]
rainbow rub it's this thing looks like
look at those little legs those little
[ __ ] bracelets for legs man what what
is this is a chihuahua this is a
six-year-old Chihuahua mix full of sass
and he bites a lot yeah and the mom is a
dog groomer and he's at the shop every
day and all the products on the animal
are plant-based and chemical free from
what plan yeah whatever that's what
night details I know a plan a chemical
plant yeah this dog looks like something
Elton John they pulled out of Elton
John's stomach this thing what how did
they get that much stuff on it yeah how
the [ __ ] did they diet so many times
this thing like looks like if it bit you
then like male pornhub we just open up
on your phone like I feel this thing
very erotic or exotic Brendon this thing
knows it's art tell you that much
and you sure it's a dog I think it looks
it looks like it's almost bred to small
sometimes you get those dogs that are so
small they're just freezing the whole
time and they're scared other
constitución yeah and they're putting
lipstick on they don't know what to do
they're not even really dogs they're
just kind of in that imposition attics
they're in the other side down yet that
is addicted they want more you know body
and legs and arms but they don't have
they didn't give them nobody can't get
it because they don't have genetics oh I
thought that was the leash on the far
right but that's his hair they spiked up
like
alfalfa mmm now I do at the end he does
look pretty like he should be he like
he's gonna move to uh you know maybe San
Francisco or something well San
Francisco treat on the right there's a
lot of kids and rappers that dress like
that these days
oh yeah he does look like a little
whatever his name is little diazepam or
something yeah yeah or whatever that
guy's name is a little Tylenol little
onion yeah I can't remember that guy's
uh I don't know any of them dudes ER
Tech or something that dude I I dude
took like mm you know a little I can't
remember his name was no claritin little
claritin yeah I do [ __ ] sneezed and
his whole body blew up yeah so a lot of
these boys on pills man yeah the dogs on
pills bro good look here's what I say if
a frisbee will kill it it's not a dog so
I'm not even accepting this thing as a
damn animal not under a frisbee and it
[ __ ] ends this thing's life son and
then ain't an animal of the Lord no
that's a fancy rank you know my face
yeah this thing is this is state this is
one of Satan's little side pieces man
and you can put this thing back in a
biscuit maker brother pan whatever color
you want to think Satan's work we got to
stand up for these animals with you bro
people submit and rats trying to pass
one over by us we too smart for that
yeah you look dressed like [ __ ] so
don't get it twisted though I look nice
a thing yeah I think you'd best you're
my wings so glowing or not dope oh okay
we have special Halloween edition of rip
my drift
these are all senators for you guys
Halloween style guys up first
this is Ashley McDonald oh she's you
theater she's you feel yeah she that
guinea pig
[Laughter]
my aunt ba this is haunt my aunt she
looks great Ashley look beautiful oh
dude Wow very much and I've Austin worn
tights like that I love that big G pig
shirt man that thing is beautiful oh
yeah a fresh snout guys awesome look at
the goatee man I get to be a Halloween
costume I love you really I mean look
like feel but you also look like goat
boy from Seneca music right you're just
jealous
something's how many ordering a pizza
who never learned how to toe I think
somebody wanted me to a dial-up internet
I said extra I love you Ashley that's
beautiful you get that's a nice oh yeah
a little thick I mean again buzz buzz
girl Brennan's having another candy corn
cuz he's getting nervous this is Katie
and JJ from Delaware this is wow this is
that some porno yeah I'm sorry it's he
uh the thug Michael Jackson what is that
no this is our little Red Rider with
Little Red Riding Hood in the big black
wolf so many of times I'm black this is
very common doesn't end well for a lot
of these girls that doesn't em really
well well for us bad daddy
that [ __ ] ends well every time wait for
it Rose nothing better
mmm-hmm now here's the thing his day
though like bro yeah yeah pay for the
subscription I see that icing you feel
me cuz they'll get right to it then
commercial like
I put my credit card 399 to see that
[ __ ] ice and ice and ice season baby
why talking about you guys are my boys
no I'm writing for you that life thing
for come on don't any of that so you say
it's free but you ain't getting all the
parts bro you ain't seen behind the
scenes you guys are paying extra for
black semen on the internet both do I'm
disappointed in y'all really should
celebrate celebrate with you cuz I don't
know what a little red rises not to do
here bro but again I've seen how this
ends many of times I pay hard cold gas
for that
[Laughter]
$3.99 bro wow this is ganking black
stuff bro this looks like an episode of
Dateline dude this has got to tighten up
man I can't believe that people are
really I mean I think this is great
actually
and everybody looks like they're doing
pretty well in it Oh Little Red Riding
tips I just don't want to see you know I
just I can't believe guys are paying
extra for the semen it's like it's like
watching Game of Thrones and you miss
the last you know the catch-up
you miss the thrill you just leave your
hanging I gots to know how did I know
there's semen at the end man I don't
have to I know exactly how I picture
going down then there was still a curve
ball at you and that's what I'm paying
for
no dude I don't think there's like I get
it it's like you buy a six-pack and then
you actually buy it and there's eight
there I gets a real plus I don't want to
see all that I think I'm trying to have
to see that yeah that's fine it ain't
for everybody that's why they offer that
it ain't for me man but I think it's
good it's you know it's I'm glad it's
going I'm glad everybody's having fun
but there's no how do you not know you
know what happens though there's no
curveball bro listen
no in every movie the good guys can get
away the bad guys gonna die but I like
to stick around and see what happens
yeah you're right okay well I'm glad you
guys are enjoying it I'm not watching
pornography so I'm trying not to stay
out I'm staying out of this that's the
dark arts brother yeah and I'm fully
submerged so any questions Vinny and his
lady this is Vinny and his girl and
they're both hulk hogan i like double
brothers imagine also at the end of the
night you can just have sex and it's
just like a nobody's gay here you know
we both rip their shirts off yeah they
both hurt yeah let me hear that wiener
become shots like this he was so hard of
hearing that was a crazy thing about
Hogan they didn't know it people know
that's why you really wanted to know
what's next yeah now this is a nice
couple they seem like a great couple
were they from Michigan they are I
didn't say where they were from they
didn't say new world already got old
whole new whole I was like when one goes
this whole coding the other goes as
macho man mm-hmm that's always a great
combo I like S&M Jim The Slim Jim Sam
because I'll tell you this the hardest
food to get into a damn slim jim dude if
you don't have a cutter piece or
something or bunk so it's like Italian
job getting that [ __ ] thing trying to
break into a goddamn bank vault I had to
take one over to Pep Boys get him a
crack in it
some guys are better at than others full
so I think that there's definitely
something remarkable about having that
man you can snap right into the slim jim
that beefy juicy taste Oh
oh yeah I thought you're having a heart
attack
oh is that your Macho Man macho man well
that's somebody falling off of a client
no that's what you just did that's an
alternate Wendy well it sounds like
you're doing what else yeah this is uh
Cody Cody in the game completely oh wow
games of bone and there's a black guy on
the back with that big sword and that
metal on booyah oh wow let's see here
Wow
cool man I'll go shred city yeah and
look at the tits on that one huh talk
about the dragon I did that's like at
the chocolate body I thought that was a
woman that's an Indian man I think
that's cause Drago damn body videos man
I'm sorry the fairy in the myth in the
far left second one in yeah no no no I
know that fairy let's talk about the guy
oh yeah they dressed up as Elton John in
the group daddy when is jared leto this
Halloween Jared let me see the gold man
oh I know who he is all right
I feel you bro favorite character I love
that that booyah that's at Halloween
Festival style
these people are festive they got
festival garb on they got all look at
that Jon Snow got together as a team bro
easy they got what's-her-name Little Red
Riding whatever devil lady that lady
with the [ __ ] fire you got CLE C or
whatever the drug the mother of the
dragons with them smokey ovaries bruh oh
yeah
Jon Snow mr. steal your [ __ ] ponytail
yeah mr. steel yes [ __ ] weather bro
oh yeah bro um yeah beautiful group
shutout enjoy your Halloween happy
Halloween to you guys up next this is
this one might be my favorite this is
Derek and his lady okay they're Colonel
Sanders
Anna she's a chicken cluck cluck
get that [ __ ] she's that thick
drumstick oh yeah that's my favorite
type bro let's take a let's Sheridan
right there yeah she looks like she
likes dark meat I like this man
pic and look at him he definitely looks
almost like he might have a little bit
of junk in the trunk look at the front
of his pants have a lot of day care boy
boy back in that [ __ ] it looks like
he's wearing a diaper backwards any
wedding he's back in a chicken tender
look his dick goes to the gym barely
smuggling drumsticks in the wow this guy
seemed like a nice guy
hey cruel Sanders tab racist yeah I
don't think so it's a white guy that as
a business mmm it's races about that
Brendan I don't know I just get a weird
vibe I know I don't trust them I don't
try something hope is that like a really
black p-diddy party like you're gonna be
like all black people there hmm no
wonder if you'd get away with it
Oh like a white party you mean yeah but
well black people but they're all
wearing white I think he's just a nice
old man that does the chicken man I
don't think he did anything if you look
at the commercials there's never any
slaves or anything in the back you know
well not now but I guess you could read
up on the history of the business I'm
not sure where the business was located
he does have that delicious seasoning on
his chicken you a KFC or Popeye's guy
who Popeyes I'm Popeye yeah me too
anyone tried the Popeye chicken sandwich
it tastes like Popeyes didn't taste good
fillet though I haven't got it yet I
haven't had it but I know how it tastes
it tastes exactly like Popeye well I
guess it's the bomb everything a Popeyes
tastes like Popeyes the same it's like
[ __ ] salt pop I was good bro yeah this
when I die bury me inside that [ __ ]
paw Paw's dude and there's one people
always kill each other at a during Mardi
Gras on st. Charles Avenue in New
Orleans fighting over the chicken I
don't know you just got to go there
early unless you if you want to get food
without the violence murder yeah what
else go good early great costume though
right that big old chick will end it on
some King it or stinger
Halloween Halloween guys thank you I was
coming in on Halloween doing this dude
this is Chris somebody farted in my seat
I was from somewhere out I just thought
things brand-new do they smell that
cheap plastic Sam this suit just farted
bro very shocking this is a Chris boys
good dang buzz buzz King under sting
it's rough with people adult
trick-or-treaters oh my god well what do
we just say man I have no clue is it J
shop be honest immediate is that him I
think so dude what just happened I have
no idea I was scared from the get-go
though can i play that again Derek oh my
god this is scariest thing I've seen
Brandon ding ding buzz buzz oh that's a
Dutch English stinger
adult trick-or-treaters and that's a
that's what he looks like
read this that's what he looks like
is that Danny DeVito no what's the math
is that day in DeVito mask I'm not sure
they got some shake umbrellas handy but
taken the sternum Nuggets boy them
Headey pieces you got them he D pieces
you know a lot of your body warmth eyes
in your tits and here nice that to pin
your heads just bro see your eyes stay
warm really you know I am a lanch wear
four hats but I'm gonna do this guy it's
getting out not healthy this guy seems
like a librarian right outside of hell
dude this is very alarming do you see
the guy he doesn't um he has that his
suit has electricity in it yeah and then
he takes that mask off and has just a
white it's just like an old man face but
then you don't have old man here cuz
look at this here at the top I'm going
to age in this guy's Asian to me look at
no chest hair ooh that's a great point
let me just see his body
mm-hm is there a shot at the walls oh
there you go ooh that could be that's an
Asian belly mm-hmm got that seat but
that rare were like very northern Asian
what is that called cats a real white
cat where they're real yeah beige ins
yeah
what is it who's the whitest Asian um I
want to see Koreans Wow because they
they live in the snow
that's a Korean oh my god they do mm-hmm
oh I don't even know it makes me feel
sad that might be Trin I could see that
being chin a little buddy has hair oh
[ __ ] that could be a wig though Jackie
Chan maybe know if I could see his
nipples I'd know what we're dealing with
there no you wouldn't every time they
keep the nips give it away dude you're
better than that
I promise what do you think here Derrick
what do people say
fifty percent this question adult
trick-or-treaters I say let him rip a
lot of people don't get to live the
childhood they want to live so they
don't really get that freedom to dress
up and did you come to my door and
you're over 30 I'm kicking in the day
over 30 same way you guys really good
you know
yes leeway bro hurry up you can't come
to the crib I respect that actually CID
bro my son you check your ID 13 up 29
years old Lin 29 you get a nice [ __ ]
Butterfinger for your stupid face open
up that hot sack do it and we just have
a neighbor he would do actual buttering
you put his finger in butter and just
let you touch it just like you suck his
finger yeah if you want it I just
touched it
yeah yeah you can touch it with the
inside of your mouth if you want you can
what touched it
that's your whole trick I'm gonna say
[ __ ] sting growing up [ __ ] good
shake it baby I like these guys and I
like people's still enjoying the youth
ma'am all right you got a live for
everyone [ __ ] boys this is Jacob from
Indiana it's big Jacob what's up Joe
bronies
I got a king under sing it for you
Brendan pumpkin carving you slice
through that orange hitter or is that
not your thing and if you are cutting
into one are you cutting off the top or
the bottom person to me I cut out the
bottom because this lives longer hey us
but let me know what y'all think let's
[ __ ] and I got a little Halloween joke
for you how do you know that a vampire
has a cold cuz there's a coffin anyways
take care in gang boo boo gang bruh boo
bro
this better not thought it was gonna be
me - um dude definitely cut the bottom
of the pumpkin where you're [ __ ] Isis
did you cut the top on your goddamn
American and you dig out the gut yeah
the bottom I'm even heard that [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] out here you can't not the
bottoms of the pumpkins yeah you cut out
the bottom man they cut out the [ __ ]
top the stem you got stam dude we're
Americans
that's Isis no that's Russian in the
back it is yes Russia in the back
American in the front middle yeah what
are you that Isis guy there that they
just call it man um any artist as they
call him just just pumpkins and jump
pumpkin it's a real beast man punk is a
real commitment I love pumpkin carving
you know and uh and that is not a urban
that's some people think it's an urban
person's name pumpkin carving but uh
it's not that is a sport around
Halloween do you see that one guy know
his name he just I think he made Alice
use names like the best to ever do it
yeah the ice coldest year yeah real name
ice the best ice cold real name come
here to LSU look Derek instead of
looking up the guy's name wondering what
his name could be I love Derek sense of
wonder he's like man that's crazy really
we'll never know was there some place we
could go to search that which it was a
magic portal no just go oldest Dakotas
Dakotas the best there it is the coldest
to ever do it Crawford gang you can't
say his name without sanding a little
urban do cold us to ever do it cross try
saying that it white it's tough you
can't doc coldest to ever do it I revert
to coldest to ever do it Crawford a mom
and I want a dope-ass name bro mind your
name bro honking carving that's a good
name pumpkin Carver the third yeah Brad
yeah sounds pretty elegant pumpkin
Carver the third bro he must be [ __ ]
good if you want to tell us you he I
hope he's the coldest ever do it always
getting up working and a [ __ ] ice
cream shop coalesced ever do thank you
my [ __ ] 6-inch sub no dude actually
actually it's kind of interests because
he could then open up an ice cream place
and it would probably do great called
the coldest coldest well he's a
superstar says Wow
the coldest Dakota Crawford
see his mom and dad Oh brah the code is
their coldest ever may be the coldest
ever do sex
they gotta be okay this gentleman we say
in the carving pumpkins man king
pumpkins is once a year just have fun
with it
there's nothing's more annoying than
when you [ __ ] up and it's the Aizen that
knows too close together and then one
[ __ ] falls through it's the worst yeah
you got to pump can carving is something
that you learn over time too the first
couple times you messed it up you cut
the mouth out and you do the teeth wrong
and then you got to push them out with
the knife and you screw it all up here's
a little tip you delinquents lie stick a
marker draw it first and then cut bro
yeah it's a tip it's easy if you like to
be a challenge you'd like to be the Bear
Grylls you just get in there with a
knife do you get into the spoon and see
what happens yeah we used to cut it with
my we had a neighbor that would cut it
with a blowtorch she did welding bra and
he just weld that [ __ ] make pumpkin pie
after just like make us so he couldn't
you it was hard to do like a face but he
would really get in there it's pretty
articulate he's good with the eyes he
did some unique things but um king
pumpkins yeah king pumpkins man hell
yeah pumpkin carving yeah I think it's
an eel be a national sport I would love
to see people really get into it I could
see we were watching that on like a dude
and Food Network herself telling this
thing I went to last night these
pumpkins the the I posted a picture of
it this some of these pumpkins are
straight-up artwork man there were
dinosaurs there Kanye West pumpkin Adam
Sandler pumpkin hmm nuts
um and Brian Johnson studio you can find
him on Instagram he did our pumpkin
right here oh did Brian do this yep
that's my boy um he dropped it off
yesterday oh wow
and he did um he did some as well he did
a really dope Rat King when brought to
show it to you that's cool yeah it was
pretty pretty cool so thank you Brian
thanks Brian shot to Brian happy
Halloween everybody happy Halloween
everybody be safe out there
he'll be safe love yourself Derek you
got any message for the people at a
trick-or-treating I'll be safe out there
keep it black and white
keep it whatever color you want to keep
it dog yeah but keep it a little black
but mostly black here yeah a little
black number bad yeah that's true the
coldest the coldest
I'm being doused in Salt Lake City
November get your tickets yeah I'm gonna
be in
I'll be at The Wiltern in Los Angeles on
12:10 December 10th in Lafayette
Louisiana it's almost sold out actually
and that's gonna be in December 26 and
we're gonna be raising some money some
of the proceeds for Dustin Poirier
cherry down they had a good fight
foundation so happy to be down there
it's gonna be fun
Buzzz Buzzz gang gang gang gang
Halloween the people cats here yeah
sugar comb and everybody gang gang sugar
high
[Music]